I've seen lots of battles
I saw liar I saw a man kill another man
just outside a Tavern in flea bottom
three men fighting isn't a battle they
could all on top I know Gendry what
makes a fight into a battle
so when they've got armor on and he told
you that tonight how'd you know it was a
night well cuz he got on mom it'd have
to be a knight to have armor any idiot
can buy on are too nice
did I sold armor what's that smell dead
people
you sour change to make it right
the secret try the studies and you break
them with a matter that's where the real
flavor is you crush them up real fine
and then when you're finished sprinkle
over the piper jacket I saw him what
what well they're writing on the gates
of yours go on Patrol hello mine is sour
cherries is all crushed up and ready
shut up
probably in the pie crust by now in the
oven the nice warm oven shut up if we
were going north we should have come to
the red Fork River by now maybe already
passed it it's a hundred feet wide how
could we have passed it the Brotherhood
asked me the mountain them what we're
looking for they'll bring us back and
put rats in us he's got nothing to fear
from us son the Lords of Westeros want
to burn the countryside we're trying to
save it
come on we'll talk some more over brown
bread Institute and then you can go on
your way
half the country's starving and look at
this one they beat the reason off
because she's got it
I'm not stop wins a hell Rafael you sure
you sure made something what is it
wolf
yes it is goodbye help by Campari it's
really good good new pie's wonderful
Thanks be my best
the good kidney pie is all about the
ingredients flour lard water eggs milk
don't get me started on the gravy very
difficult to get right
see a lot of people give up on the gravy
you cannot give up on the gravy no gravy
no pie simple as that
it's nice armor you and I know
o people with armor is usually Knights
Germany speaking in keys landing though
on you from there myself originally flea
bottom born and bred
did you give her this you start the last
one I gave of it this one turned out
better finally good [ __ ] - mmm
think so did you meet the big lady lady
the lady Knight
yeah few she was an IKE she had on Rob
thanks to the pie friends don't pay I'm
leave a full euro boy your pre thanks
take care of yourself hot pie try not to
get killed
I'll wait I'm not you re I'm a survivor